oh my god you're Taylor Swift getting
very emotional on Monday night's episode
of The Voice look close those are real
tears oh the mega mentor explains why
she got so choked up seeing young
performers who so firmly have their
musical identity figured out I was so
completely shattered by it I fully fell
apart it was that good ah I love that
now this all goes down while Taylor is
helping out - hello Sunday from Team
Kelly it's amazing how well you connect
literally at any age that would have
moved me like that and to be fair they
are really good
I was so completely shattered by it I
fully fell apart
singing almost is never enough by Ariana
Grande and Nathan Sykes thought it would
be the perfect song to evoke emotions
and after Taylor breaks down even Kelly
can't believe it the amount that you
were connecting with each other the
amount that you were then facing out and
connecting with the audience oh my god
and obviously the girls were shocked too
when she walked on that stage with tears
in her eyes like they weren't just there
they were there it is shortest that we
can actually move people when we sing I
promise I'm okay in my personal life
this is from some outside place
this all comes after Kelly and Taylor
shared another sweet moment on last
week's show I just loved the chorus of
this song so much Yolo is being a part
of me like I love that hook and I just
kind of want to find those moments where
you can reflect that melody a really
good idea that you just made me think of
would it be cool to start on the cord
yep like the drums hitting different
parts of it that are like you'll always
be we also know Taylor and Kelly have a
super solid friendship if you'll
remember Kelly had Taylor's back when it
came to her master recordings did you
see what you did you see the Taylor
Swift is now gonna rerecord her music
and it's because you suggested no it's
not what woman is the smartest business
woman I've ever seen in this industry
all right guys that's it for today
Taylor will be on Monday and Tuesday's
episode of The Voice and for all the
latest on her and Kelly keep it locked
to all things et until next time I'm
Katie Krauss and bye for now
you